you sometimes have to kick yourself to
remind you of ourselves this common
descent I think particularly of
birds-of-paradise which I happened to
just for some idiosyncratic reason they
obsess by and you'd look at the variety
of plumage and the variety of coloration
and the variety of lifestyles and making
performances and you cannot believe that
these things some of which are sides are
robbing and some of which incites were
crow
some of which are scarlet and some of
which are yellow some of which have pins
on their heads and some of which have
rooms
coming out for the front of their wings
and think they're all the same family
you don't realize that until you look at
the females and then you suddenly see if
you can strip away the sexual display
elephant they have a very very similar
and then the reality comes home to you
but it's quite a hard effort I mean
gorillas are fascinating because they
are so like us and I can imagine what
it's like to be a gorilla and I mean I
really can and I think they they accept
us in a curious way but but when you
look compared to paradise you realize
that there's a whole aspect of life of
the quiddity the essence of a free life
which don't know you do with humanity
now and which has been going on before
primates even there appeared on earth
but is when you sit concealed in a hide
and you see the complexity of the
natural world going on with these
extraordinary manifestations of which
strike you subjectively has been
amazingly beautiful and you see all that
pollinating with with vigor variety
passion
that you realize that humanity is not
dominant in the world and there's only a
very small part of it and that's what I
find moving
you